قصه جميله مليئه بالمشاعر الدافئه يعادل
مقطع قصير لاب سعوديه يحتضن ابنته متاثرا
بتخرجها من جامعه الملك خالد خطف الانظار
والقلوب انها مشاعر الاب مهما كان هو سعود
القحطاني مع ابنه سميره التي كفلها قبل 22
عام
سلطان القحطاني كان يعمل رئيسا لقسم
التمريض باحد المستشفيات عندما كانت سميره
الرضيعه في حضانه المستشفى ومكثت هناك
لمده تسعه اشهر دون ان يستلمها احد
اصطحبها العم سلطان الى منزله وعرض على
زوجته وابنائه كفالتها واحتضانها ومنذ ذلك
الحين يقول الاب انها ادخلت السرور
والبهجه على هذه الاسره سلطان القحطاني
وابنته معنا مشاهدا مشاهدينا يرويان القصه
في صباح
[موسيقى]
العربيه
ينضم الينا من ابها سلطان القحطاني والد
الخريجه سميره سلطان القحطاني نقول لكم
الف مبروك اول شيء
وتشوفها ان شاء الله في اعلى المراتب
وتفرح فيها وهذه المشاعر الصادقه هي مشاعر
الاب بالتاكيد صبحكم الله بالخير
يا هلا ومرحبا يعني العم سلطان خلني اسالك
بانه اول مره اليوم
شعورك هو ذات الفرحه اللي كانت قبلها 22
سنه
ولا تختلف والله نفسها الان اكثر واكثر
يعني خلاص صارت سميره قطعه من قلبي من
كبدي او يعني كنا فيها شفقه وكذا ورحمه
وبنته وكنا نحبها ما نحبها لكن الان لا
الوضع يختلف جدا الان سميره عيوني وقلبي
وروحي
يا سلام
قلبي بالضبط والاب هو الذي يربي طبعا
فيصبح ابنائه فعلا فلذات اكباده حتى
بالتربيه يعني طيب سلطان انا انا حابه
اسال سميره سميره شو كان شعورك وخصوصا لما
تفاعل كل رواد مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي مع
هذه الصوره اللي بالفعل تطفئ القلوب انت
ووالدك في التخريج
كلهم شاركوني فرحتي
ايوه يا سميره سامعينك تفضلي
يعني كلهم شاركوني فرحتي الحمد لله
جميل طيب طبعا انت يعني مشاعرك احنا طبعا
نتحدث عن انه 22 عام من الحب والرعايه حتى
تتوج بهذا التخريج يعني كيف وصلت الى هنا
يعني الحمد لله بفضل الله ثم بفضل اهلي
قولي يا سميره طيب سميره خليني اسالك انا
والله ما راح اخليك كله لما تقولي لي انه
هذه اللحظه شو اللي حسيت فكرتي فيه وايضا
العم سلطان لما شفت سميره وهي خريجه
وقالوا اسمها ايش فكرت فيه
سالي ولا لا والله اثنينكم ابي كل واحد
يقول لي بهذا اللحظه كنت تفكروا
يعني الحمد لله
يعني شنو هو الشعور قولي لي ههه
[موسيقى]
شنو شعورك بهذيك اللحظه
اثناء المسيره
شعور انا اعتبره رهيب في جسمي
وكنت اتخيل وكانت تمشي لوحدها وما فيها
اهل لها ولا احد في المدرجات يشاركها
فرحتها وشعورها هذا اللي خلاني انا يعني
انهار وابكي لو كانت تمشي لوحدها لكن الله
سبحانه وتعالى يسر لنا حتى الدخول الى
المنصه وكنا قريب منها اثناء المسيره انا
انا والله انا انا اسف اني راح اسالك
هالسؤال بس والله لازم اسئله حتى حتى وصل
رساله البعض يقول بلي تفرح الى هالدرجه
العم سلطان ما هي ما هي من صلبك شو ترد
عليه
والله الذي لا اله الا هو والله الذي لا
اله الا هو ان هذا البنت انها نصف واولادي
الثمانيه والبنات
افرح لها هذه يعني احس انها قطعه من قلبي
ومن فؤادي
عاشت معي 22 سنه
حسيت بسعاده بوجودها في بيتي عسى الله
باطمئنان وجودها معنا
الله الله يجزاك خير الله يجزاك خير
ويرزقك برهه وان شاء الله ترد لك
يعني الخير هذا اللي قدمته دائما شكرا
العم سلطان القحطاني وابنته سميره ان شاء
الله فالك الدكتوراه كما يقولون ولا بس
خلاص باذن الله ولا بس خلاص وقفنا
ان شاء الله تقول ان شاء الله
عسى الله يوفقك عسى الله يوفقك
لمتابعتي المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات